hey guys what's up i'm so excited for
you to watch this interview before we
get into this interview i want to talk
about our sponsor
prime xbt if you're trading bitcoin
you got to be using primex bt not only
do they have global markets
available to anyone but they also have
great execution
low fees and an amazing user interface
the best part about primexpt is that you
can also follow some of the best traders
in the world
you go on you find someone who you think
is smart and you can literally just
follow their trades when they execute
something your portfolio executes the
same
and if you think you're one of the best
traders in the world then you can simply
go on there and have people follow you
and you earn a little extra income by
having those followers
so if you're trading bitcoin anywhere in
the world you got to use primex bt
they've won multiple awards for being
one of the best trading platforms
in crypto you can trade spot markets or
even use margin
so go on over to use primexpt you can go
to the description and click on the link
there
all right let's get into this episode
today i really hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i have
katherine here with me thank you so much
for doing this
thank you so much for having me it's
great to be here for sure let's just
jump right in to uh i think a topic that
you've covered extensively
uh is this idea of kind of silicon
valley and tech innovation
uh leading and maybe washington
bureaucracy and kind of political policy
uh not necessarily being the driving
force behind a lot of progress and
change
at least in the current state um maybe
just start off with kind of how do you
view this from a framework perspective
and then
you know why do you think that the the
pendulum is kind of swung in favor
of technology and that sector versus the
policy side
sure well this is this is something i've
been thinking about for for a long time
which is
you know there's this understanding i
think whether you're on the left the
right whether you follow politics at all
that government is broken
and it's a meme but no one really talks
about why so i started digging into like
why has this happened
and a lot of the thesis or a lot of the
theories that i have relate to the fact
that a lot of the talent
is no longer going into the bureaucracy
if you look at you know
post-world war ii we had a a society
where everyone served public service was
part of the conversation everyone had
served in the military
and that changed in 1973 with the change
in conscription
and i do think that that has had a huge
impact on
how our elites how people who go to
college which also became something you
know that
a lot of people did after after the 70s
uh
how they thought about public service
and what i think is happening
is a lot of people are coming to silicon
valley who would have otherwise served
their country in a different time period
and so what you're seeing in the sort of
last generation of technology companies
is really great people who are inspired
to do something
and to solve a problem but the
government just stopped solving because
of stagnation in the government
and so you know i i focus on highly
regulated industries from aerospace
defense uh financial technology
healthcare
these are areas where all of the
innovation is coming from
silicon valley and technology it's not
coming from policy makers there hasn't
been an innovative policy in any of
these sectors in a very long time
if we do have legislation that is that
somehow passes
despite the gridlock in washington none
of it is really
innovative and sometimes it gets
reversed so there's all of these
questions about if we're thinking about
where are we actually solving problems
in society
a lot of our best and brightest talent
is coming to silicon valley and they're
building companies
that that go against what washington's
doing and so
i've referred to this as the shadow
capital um when you look at what elon
musk has done elon musk has done
more for climate change than most
countries in the world uh
he's done you know more for for
aerospace engineering and more for
for something that was so important to
the government he's built a massive
government company
um that then you know that anything that
has happened kind of in a government you
know research lab or that sort of thing
uh and i think he's sort of the
canonical example of this if you want to
fix a massive
societal civic problem it's better to do
it through technology
and you can go down the list of all of
the government departments that exist
whether it's you know department of
education all of the interesting
initiatives that are happening in
education are coming from
from founders and and that's what's
exciting to me but i think it's also a
change
in silicon valley culture that people
are really trying to solve civic needs
and so why do you think silicon valley
is kind of winning that war for talent
is this something where
um it's just the mindset is different
and so people are going there is it
maybe something where these people would
have gone into the military previously
and there's been like a societal change
now that's taboo and so
technology is kind of the accepted path
uh just
unpack a little bit more just like why
it's happening so i mean i think those
are those are two great reasons so i i
do think that there has been a change
in kind of what is expected of american
elites
there used to be this idea that you
would give back to your country um and
it didn't matter if you were
you know very poor raised on a farm as a
lot of people were
in in you know in the in world war ii or
if you
had gone to yale or harvard uh you were
expected that kind of the idea of what
it means to be
a good citizen is to serve in some way
and and it used to be that we served
through through military service
and i think that changed that definitely
shifted and and we became this
this culture that was incredibly focused
on on you know like
the financialization of the culture made
us incredibly focused on
finance in many ways and what's really
interesting over the last
15 years i would say just looking at the
data is that the number of
university students that are going into
financial services after graduating if
you look at say the top 10 colleges
has just risen dramatically and i do
think that that is part of the reason
why when people are thinking how do we
actually solve problems
capital is incredibly cheap uh and more
and more people know how to code
and so if you are someone who is truly
ambitious about solving problems and you
say to yourself i can either go to
washington and be a staffer
for a low-level senator and help write
policy that may or may not get passed
or i can go to silicon valley with my
friends
build something that's controversial
that's contrarian that's really cool
but i believe in solving this mission uh
nine times out of ten i think the most
ambitious smartest people are going to
be doing that
and so you do see this sort of kind of
migration that's happened and i actually
you know think the social network the
the film that came out in 2010 is
actually one of the
the kind of cultural moments where
people realized wow like
there is a reason to come out and build
technology companies and that sort of
brought the normies with them you know
like it used to be that all the
all the nerds and sort of the the you
know crypto weirdos were hanging out in
silicon valley and like now it's like no
it's actually
uh you know the normies have decided
that they want to do this too
and i think that just changes the
calculus and
that has also led to a massive backlash
in washington against silicon valley
because when you lose your talent when
you lose your capital and when you lose
your ability to build
and a shadow capital emerges on the
opposite coast
that makes people really frightened it
almost feels like by celebritizing
uh the founders and the companies that
were built
you change the narrative and the second
that that becomes uh kind of culturally
relevant and aspirational now all of a
sudden you can bring the numbers you can
bring people
uh and really that's what if you look at
content
uh kind of hollywood etc uh wall street
was in the 80s and 90s right and now all
of a sudden it's kind of shifted to uh
uh to silicon valley uh when you think
through this um so that shift in capital
uh both intellectual and financial uh
has
set up this like shadow capital uh of
silicon valley
let's unpack that a little bit in terms
of what exactly do you mean when you say
a shadow capital
uh and then what are the pros and the
cons of having these types of shadow
capital when you look at it from uh
kind of managing a society or an economy
sure so so
i would argue there's always been shadow
capitals throughout history
often times in various countries so so
the example that i've pointed to when
i've written about this
is the example of united fruit where if
you look at central america
at the turn of the century united fruit
was a fruit company based in new orleans
uh that was basically running most of
central america
uh it was you know the big industry of
the time
uh you know the the founder happened to
live in new orleans and so or not the
founder actually the ceo
happened to live in new orleans and and
that's where he wanted to to headquarter
the company
and he was running the the postal
service of nicaragua
uh and so when you when you think about
examples like that it's like okay
there are companies that have run
governments before
um and it's usually you know it it
usually has something to do with kind of
just acquisition of land like it was the
largest landowner in
in latin america or sorry not latin
america central america
and so it makes sense that okay you have
a lot of capital that's going into a
region
throughout history or you have you know
a la uh one company that owns a ton of
the land
uh that would make sense why a capital
would emerge or would have just kind of
um a surprising amount of political
cachet and political uh
power in a certain country but what i
think is really different about silicon
valley acting as a shadow capital
is that the technology coupled with this
capital issue
allows individual companies to grow
massive to the point where they can
replace or you know supplement a
department in government
so i point to the the example of uber
and lyft which has completely changed
how we think about public transport
the department of transportation
probably the only thing they are
thinking about is why cities across
america are losing
extraordinary amounts of revenue to
companies that can
provide public services of getting
around a city much better
than public transport has been able to
do over the last you know 30 40 years
excluding the new york metro or uh
subway or dc metro but like
but in terms of actually being able to
travel around cities um this is
this is a huge problem for cities and so
you know this the emergence of a shadow
capital
i think the difference that we are
seeing is that individual companies can
grow
within five to seven years and
completely supplant
uh a a bureaucracy a bureaucratic
function of government
a department of government um and that
makes people nervous
and so when that happens is that an
argument for actually we should have a
really really small government we should
outsource kind of all of these functions
to private companies
uh or is it actually good to have
government trying to accomplish it even
if they're ineffective and
and kind of uh bloated and bureaucratic
uh because it gives
the private company something to almost
compete with right like it's it's almost
to some degree
the competition breeds the innovation um
or is it just
no actually we're just wasting a bunch
of money time and resources and
let's just outsource all this to
technology companies or to uh
to the private industry so it's it's a
really good question and i think the
it's not a one-size-fits-all answer um
so you know when you look at so
so i invest a lot in defense technology
uh the department of defense
has a lot of people who work in the
department of defense who are incredibly
good at their jobs incredibly you know
useful like
they can't be replaced by a private
company but we've done a really good job
since world war
ii outsourcing uh a lot of the you know
a lot of the functions
that that need to be done like we we
outsource you know
manufacturing uh tanks and battleships
to
five prime contractors and so you know
that is important i think from
from you know the the types of
technologies that cannot be built by
government
need to be built by a third party by a
commercial sector
and i think one of the greatest
misconceptions of government when it's
looking at software is that it thinks it
can
build software but it actually can't um
you know
and i know you know this there's a huge
difference between someone who thinks
they're a software engineer that can
build a simple
you know build a simple line of code
versus someone who can actually build
um you know ai at a sophisticated level
where they could work at one of the best
companies so i think that's something
that the government has has
misunderstood widely
uh so when you start to think about kind
of innovation um
and true innovation is it more so that
the government through the policy
decisions they make
are changing incentives but they're not
actually trying to accomplish innovation
and it's more so how do they empower
incentivize other uh private sector to
do it
uh or do we think that there's examples
where the government actually has driven
true innovation
so there's i mean there's definitely
examples throughout history where the
government has driven
true true innovation and i think you
know um
the government tends i mean i'd say the
research labs which are a very important
function in government like
like do do bleeding edge work i mean
darpa has has done incredible work in
terms of pushing the boundaries of
science and i think like
that is an important function of
government it is hard to turn
those technology you know like the
technological shifts that darba works on
into true innovation that can be
commercially
used and i think that's that is the
difference is when when
you know government is investing in sort
of leading-edge science or technology
it's often not in the service of
building a company or or building
something that can actually
you know solve a business need in
government um and so i think that that's
why
when you actually look at how government
and particularly the department of
defense has worked with
private sector it's actually you know an
important partnership and so i would
never say
you know you know private sector should
completely supplant
like the the way that government
functions i think as a partnership it
actually does work
um but the times have changed so a lot
of the the ways that government works
with
uh the commercial sector and
particularly um
around issues of procurement they were
built for a totally different era of
pre-software
they were built pre-internet and so the
idea that government understands how to
build a company
or how to to build an important
technology that can be used
to solve a business need a lot of the
ways in which government thinks that
it can it can build is just a dated way
of building and and you and i both know
like you know the the
pace at which someone can build a
company in silicon valley when they have
the right team
when they're able to recruit the right
people when they have the capital to
move forward
is so extraordinary and it's unlike any
energy and any pace that exists anywhere
else in the world
building a startup is so different
than working in government than asking
for approval at a large company
and so i think that's part of the
cultural problem is that
you know if you've only ever worked in
policy you don't understand the pace at
which things can be built
uh by a motivated team with with
technology and capital
is that an argument then to be made that
uh we shouldn't have
either career politicians or people who
only work in government like should
there be some requirement before you can
participate in public service or at some
point during public service
you have to go work in the private
sector and it's less about
um kind of you know corruption or any of
the really extreme examples and it's
more so just about
making sure that the freshest most
innovative ideas mindset and
kind of mental models really are being
used for those that govern the
population
you know i think one of the biggest
problems is that a lot of people in
government have
no idea how technology works that's
actually one of our biggest
problems and could actually be a
national security risk in many ways if
we don't fix that problem and so
i do think that there there needs to be
more people
in in in silicon valley and in true
innovation
that that understand how policy works
and vice versa that people who
are lifetime you know bureaucrats and
people who run for office
have some experience in in business and
and and particularly in technology so
they understand
the pace at which things are done uh
other ways to solve
problems i mean when we talk about
building a company it really is solving
a problem
and so you know washington and silicon
valley have the exact same aims of how
do we solve problems to benefit the most
people but they're doing it in different
ways
so it actually makes perfect sense uh
that you would you would do stints in
both to really understand
when can you solve problems with policy
when are you know when are problems best
solved by by people in washington and
vice versa
when can you sell them with technology
yeah one of the kind of tangential
issues
uh to this that i've been thinking a lot
about and i don't have the answer yet
right
is uh if you think of kind of power
structure and also centralization versus
decentralization the
legacy world was centralized entities uh
and the government had the kind of
superior power
over them right they could go they could
put a founder
leadership in jail they could shut down
servers they could kind of you know if
they really didn't like what somebody
was doing they could obviously or they
felt it was threatening
they had a kind of um you know a
response to that
uh and so the first question is just
like you know who's actually more
powerful today silicon valley or
washington and uh i think it's almost
like
based on topic you may get a different
answer there which scares some people
and other people just think it's kind of
the foreground conclusion but then two
it leads into this kind of second order
effect well
if that ends up being this case uh one
of the defense mechanisms may be more
decentralization because it actually
uh serves as this ability to uh to
prevent some of those responses and so
how do you think through you know the
power structure like maybe who is more
powerful in certain situations
uh and then just centralization versus
decentralization and if that's important
at all or how you see that playing out
yeah i mean it's a i think it's one of
the most important questions of our time
and it's also
really hard to pinpoint sort of you know
how how do we quantify power
uh because what what i think is is is
very interesting is there's
i almost call it establishment versus
anti-establishment
and you know washington is definitely
you know governments are part of
traditional establishments but there's
other parts of those establishments
there's
uh you know the fourth estate which is
the media there's uh institutions like
the roman catholic church there's
institutions
you know that that exists far beyond
just governmental authorities but they
are establishment authorities they're
university systems harvard university is
part of the establishment
and then i would actually argue that a
lot of companies no matter what their
size are
our anti-establishment and how they are
founded and how they think about solving
problems
and you know the vast majority of
startups start up as an
anti-establishment cry
against one of these elite institutions
like how do we fix something that the
establishment hasn't been able to do
um in terms of who's more powerful what
i what i
think i see happening is that a lot of
the power has shifted on
specific issues and if you're trying to
solve the specific say policy issue say
you're trying to solve
upskilling of the american workforce you
know companies like guild education and
lambda school
are doing that in extraordinary ways and
they're doing it to solve a specific
policy problem that government was
supposed to solve but just hasn't gotten
around to solving or hasn't figured out
a way to solve it effectively
um and so you know those companies i
would say
are they more powerful than the
department of education like
likely no but they're actually effective
in a way that the department of
education is not being effective
um you know when you look at say uh you
know the new york times versus sub stack
i would say like sub stack has emerged
as one of the most important companies
in that it is aggregating
extraordinary thinkers and allowing them
to to build their own followings and
and and make money in a way that they
weren't able to make money when they
worked in traditional press
you know is is one company more powerful
than say a company that's been around
100 years that is sort of seen as like
the the
establishment newspaper of america uh
you know
at three years at three years in
probably not but at the same time it is
so important to to what is happening in
the country and in it and
it's actually making people nervous of
how quickly it's moving and so
power like it's hard to say something is
more powerful given that a lot of these
institutions have have been entrenched
in society
but the fact that there are companies
that have been around for only a few
years
that are solving problems more
effectively and becoming
so important in our daily life that that
shows that
technology can move faster and it's a
perfect example of sort of this shadow
capital mentality which is that people
who are motivated to solve a specific
problem can solve it much quicker
outside of the institutions than inside
them one
aspect of this that i think people may
not understand is like there's a
technology argument you made right if i
write certain uh amount of code in a
certain way
and you don't then i may have an
advantage from from a pure technology
kind of capability functionality
standpoint but what seems to be
the even bigger moat is actually the
kind of knowledge of silicon valley the
experience and just the years and years
and years of doing this and so
for you know a kind of direct example of
substance substance taking a platform
approach
rather than saying we're just going to
go build an anti-establishment
media company in a traditional sense is
very different than what the new york
times and other kind of legacy companies
have
have done now there may be coexistence
of those two models but as we know from
the silicon valley kind of playbook
the platform play can be much more
scalable can be much faster growing
it's much harder to kind of compete with
and if you get you know some level of
network effect whether it's a true
network effect or something that looks
like it
uh it's just really really hard to
unseat that and so
is it when we talk about technology is
it more the playbook than the actual
technology itself
or is it no there's actually technology
in like some of these companies and
governments they just can't write the
code and build the functionality that's
needed to actually
kind of compete in a free market you
know i think you're touching on
something really important because i
actually think it's it's mindset
and it's it's understanding the culture
so i moved to silicon valley in 2014.
i i was a reporter at the washington
post before that
um and i i had lived around the world
and and when i moved to california i
joked that it was the worst culture
shock that i'd ever had in my life
it felt like i was in a totally
different planet
and you know some people take to that i
completely took to it i was like i
finally
met the culture that i want to be a part
of um but it was
it took a while to learn it took a while
to learn the cultural cues it took a
while to understand
oh you don't have to ask for permission
oh there's no there's no governing
authority here oh people don't really
care
where you went to school or or or how
you know like who your parents are you
know what
people don't ask those things there's
other things that are very important in
silicon valley that establish status
but but the things that establish status
on the east coast do not matter
and that was really surprising to me and
i think that that is part of the overall
playbook
that that maybe is misunderstood when
you've
kind of lived in um a culture that is
very hierarchical
um and i think it takes people a while
to understand that which is why you know
when i you know people make one of the
companies that i work very close with
the
anderl industries you know the founders
palmer lucky and he wears hawaiian
shirts to meetings with with generals
and what's great is that the dog loves
it you know i i've never met anyone who
hates that but it's like
there's sort of this like wow like these
you know there's a dress code difference
there's a difference in how people
you know present themselves for very
important meetings and so
my view is that people need to to kind
of learn about how various cultures work
in order to work with them be effective
you know if you're if you're running a
sales team at a company you know
the culture of your customer and you and
you fit that culture
and i think both silicon valley if
they're selling to government has to
figure that out but government
uh you know really needs to start
figuring out how silicon valley works
and really understand
the culture that it's interacting with
yeah it's a great point about mindset
versus natural technology itself um
let's talk a little bit about andrew
rowell cause i think that's probably one
of the best examples
of a company that very obviously uh is a
private organization that is doing
something that historically has been
considered kind of a public work right
and sort of defense technology
palmer obviously was the the founder of
uh what eventually became oculus
and uh had a uh a huge exit to facebook
um and now has gone into the defense
sector and so maybe just walk
through like why is now the time for a
private company to go and do this uh is
it just a technology advantage
is it a speed advantage is it actually
it's anti-establishment so therefore
they can do things the government can't
do like
why is it now um kind of the the
advantageous time to go pursue this
yeah i mean now is definitely the time
but i can tell you i wish we did it
sooner
so um when i was really um you know
researching this space spending a lot of
time with defense companies what was
shocking to me is that we have five
prime defense contractors that get over
40
of the contracts awarded by government
not just by dod
um five companies that are completely
funded by government
and they were all they were all founded
either right you know
100 years ago and became like the
dominant contractors
after world war ii so these are
entrenched legacy companies
that were built for a completely
different time they were built to build
battleships like they are hardware
companies that were incredibly necessary
that that are part of american history
and very important
but they're also massive massive
companies that still to this day get
more contracts and
and what's interesting is that i was
looking back you know at the fall of the
berlin wall
after communism there was a view that
these companies were not going to be as
important and that new companies would
be able to emerge
and there was a huge fear that spending
cuts particularly after the end of the
cold war
were going was going to lead to these
companies not succeeding and so what
they did which was
the smart business thing to do is they
acquired companies and particularly
acquired you know companies that have
contracts already so not innovative
companies like what happens in silicon
valley
they acquired companies for contracts
and something like
50 000 companies that were in the space
over 15 years
left the defense industry and by left
meaning consolidated with these massive
massive institutions which became
holding companies and when that is your
mechanism of growth
where you're just consolidating
contracts you don't need to do
innovation
and so we've had 30 years where
these prime contractors have not been
innovating and that's the same 30 years
where the internet emerged like what an
extraordinary thing to have happen where
now we're at near pier status with
russia and china our two adversaries
where 30 years ago russia was you know
russia was
coming out of the soviet union and china
was not nearly as much of the powerhouse
that it is today and so when you look at
the fact that we had this technological
advantage
you know we had this incredible capital
advantage in many ways too and
sort of world leader advantage that that
you know before
the fall of communism we didn't have
when you think about kind of what
happened
in the defense industry at that time uh
it's actually a sad story and so
you know come to 2017 where you have
extraordinary founders
a second time founder and then a team
that is spinning out of palantir which
really understands the government
playbook
looking at these macro trends and saying
how do we how do we squander this
technological
opportunity um and how do we make sure
that ai
and software become the focus of our
defense department
and what's great is that this was
something that was recognized as a huge
security risk in the department of
defense so
um former secretary of state ash carter
carter under um the obama administration
he was really focused on building up the
defense base really understood that
silicon valley needed to work with the
dod
and so he he put you know mechanism in
place to allow for companies to work
closer together
uh but it really wasn't until companies
like andrew came about and started kind
of explaining how silicon valley works
to the dod that we're now seeing this
what i would call like a defense
renaissance
where there's a number of companies that
are able to work with the department of
defense get large production contracts
and provide cutting-edge software
to the department of defense in a way
that just has never happened so
i'm really excited about this sector i
think that things have dramatically
shifted
uh but it took a long time to get there
and it's actually uh you know
in some ways it's a huge security risk
if we don't continue to support
companies that are supporting the
department of defense
uh you mentioned ash carter when i
worked at facebook i think it was in
2014
uh he came to facebook and myself and a
number of other veterans met with him
while he was there and one of the pieces
of feedback
basically was look you know it's great
that you're here it's great that you
have recognized facebook as kind of a
leader in the technology sector it's
great that you want to meet with the
veterans here
but uh there's only one engineer in the
room right because just naturally a lot
of the
veterans didn't go into uh kind of
software engineering and so
it was hey those are the people you want
to go talk to right if you really want
to solve kind of complex problems
uh they're some of the smartest people
that work at this business but also that
they can
come with solutions that non-technical
people just won't be able to do and so
it was really interesting to kind of see
his open-mindedness
to uh to just finding hey how do we
solve our problems let's go find the
smartest people within our
uh country and uh you know use them uh
to our advantage
um you one of the things that uh came
out of a recent conversation with anderl
on clubhouse was this idea of
we've gone from a game of shooting to a
game of information right and you kind
of hinted at it a little bit earlier
talk a little bit just about how uh the
private sector can empower the
government
or should we actually be saying to the
private sector hey we are going to
uh empower you to actually go out and do
the work itself so is it more so
uh the private sector kind of provides
tools and and uh services
to the government but the government is
ultimately the one that's overseeing
this and kind of the defense efforts are
uh you know kind of going through that
u.s government filter
or is this some more a thing where um
similar to if you look at uh spacex we
say no we are going to mandate you the
private business to go and
basically carry out what was previously
a public sector uh type
service um and do it as a private
company we'll give you funding we'll
kind of work with you but but ultimately
you're gonna go and carry it out how do
you see that and
are there risks in just handing it over
to the private company without having
the public sector kind of oversight
yeah so i think there i mean there will
always be public sector oversight and
that that's something that i think is
misunderstood like
when people talk about autonomous
systems you know humans are still making
decisions and there's a reason for that
and they will always make decisions like
there needs to be an accountability
mechanism and i think like that's
something that's widely understood
within the department of defense and
within the company supporting them but
this this
issue that you brought up of you know
the bombs got bigger and
and now they're smaller i think is
really really important for people to
understand and it's probably one of the
the greatest stories in human history
that we just don't talk about we don't
talk about this narrative
up until the the atomic bomb up until
1945
the bombs and the weapons that were
produced and by humans
got bigger and caused more destruction
like it was
you know there was just this this you
know we had spears and then we had guns
and
and then we had bombs and it was just it
was causing more just more destruction
it was it was one person making a
decision that affected many
and that changed with information
technology
that changed because precision and the
idea of we
we actually want to preserve people's
lives we want to reduce civilian
casualty and there are ways to do it
with information with technology
that defense can actually mean defense
it can mean deterrence
through strength that actually is is a
relatively
new phenomena and what's amazing about
artificial intelligence what's amazing
about what we've been able to do with
information is that
that it should be the future of warfare
the future of warfare should not be
civilian casualty
and so when you when you come at defense
technology through that mission uh this
is a very important mission that we need
to support because of that
uh that we need to be able to not only
protect troops on the ground but maybe
we don't need to have as many troops on
the ground
because we can use information in order
to to solve the
the problems that defense has always
been trying to solve that to me is a
very very noble mission and it's
something that
is very much ingrained in every defense
company that i
work with or know in silicon valley as
to what they are doing
and so when we talk about it in that
lens you know that is also what the you
know
department of defense and people who you
know anyone in the military is thinking
about
and so of course there's going to always
be a partnership these private companies
uh but i would say these private
companies know this and they want to
support government but
but there is this understanding across
um
across the military across people who
are engineers in these companies
that this is the mission that they are
working on um and i think that that is
um you know there's there's a narrative
in the media that people don't want to
work on defense people don't
want to be associated with it and when i
think people really sit down and see
sort of this arc of human history that
actually
things are getting less violent uh
things are getting
safer for people we're having less wars
even though the media sometimes makes it
seem like we're having more wars
like this is an extraordinary feat of
human progress and people really want to
be working on those problems to ensure
that people across the world feel safer
and can live more productive human lives
so
i think it's a very important mission i
think it's something where people who
understand
how technology is built and the arc of
technology are really motivated by it
and
as are the people who are in the
military today yeah
it is uh almost uh one of the most
patriotic things that somebody could go
do
uh which you know somehow has become
taboo as well but uh
i think we'll have a resurgence there um
i mentioned clubhouse uh where you had
this conversation with anderle i know
you've got
a show i think you just call it big
ideas which is uh
a very creative way
hey come come pay attention and listen
to the people who talk about big ideas i
love it
um what is kind of drop in audio
how are you looking that from either
investor seat or as a user
uh kind of why use that platform whether
over other platforms are there specific
advantages to it
just talk a little bit about clubhouse
and kind of the audio functionality that
uh that you seem to have found some
success with
yeah you know it it's really funny i
mean i i was just reading the clubhouse
i think this week is turning a year old
um i'm gonna be very i'm gonna give a
very personal story of why i love
clubhouse here but uh
hopefully your listeners will find it
amusing so uh my husband and i just had
our first child three months ago
and uh i found out uh
that i was expecting like the same day
that i joined clubhouse
which i think and of course the pandemic
also happened so i'm like stuck in my
house you know like my husband's getting
sick of listening to me talk who am i
gonna talk to
um and and so i just like kind of just
started hanging out on clubhouse
and you know when like i wasn't drinking
obviously because you know
like there's like not many ways you can
spend time doing a pandemic if you're
you know
not able to socialize not able to have
fun or anything so i'm just on clubhouse
all the time
uh and i also like wasn't able to sleep
very well so i was on clubhouse like
late at night talking to people
um and what's amazing about clubhouse
that i think people at least who haven't
gone through this experience of being
pregnant in a pandemic and having a
child is
it's hands-free like this is the thing
that i i've shared with paul and others
like it is amazing to me that i could be
like
holding my baby which with a newborn if
anyone's had one it's like you're
constantly with your baby and you can be
on clubhouse like
it's incredible whereas you can't be
texting you can't be you know
like on zoom calls with people like face
to face and different things but i just
so for me
if this has nothing to do with the
actual like beauty of the product i can
say a lot more about why i love this
product from like an
actual like investor perspective but for
my personal experience of clubhouse it's
just been the most extraordinary product
market fit
because you know there's this great
piece in the atlantic by a friend of
mine named sophie gilbert who wrote
about
uh the isolation of being in a pandemic
but also the isolation of being a new
mother and pandemic where you can feel
like you're not
part of society where you're just in
your home and what has been amazing for
me about clubhouse is that like all my
friends are on it
uh the conversations that are happening
i've made new friends it's been glorious
and i don't feel isolated and so the
gift that i think
paul and rohan have given to society
during a pandemic
is that people who otherwise would have
had extreme isolation
are now able to to make friends they're
able to have real conversations
and there is some magic about seeing
people live listening
uh where it is past the time for me in a
way that i think
the pandemic would have been much more
painful and i've heard that from other
users like like
i don't want like i don't want this to
go away like i love
the the idea of you know finishing
dinner and getting on clubhouse and
having an amazing conversation with
people around the world
um so i think it i i think it's
revolutionary i've enjoyed it
it's been great for my own personal life
uh but
but i'm i'm hoping you know as we come
out of the pandemic that people will
still
um be using it constantly and i think
that the beauty of the product of course
that's going to happen yeah and it feels
almost like in some weird way
uh when the pandemic hit everyone rushed
to zoom and other kind of audio video
they tried to replicate
uh all of the uh benefits or what they
thought were benefits of
in person and now what i think people
have kind of gotten zoomed out right now
they're like wait a minute actually this
is way better if i don't have to be on
video if i can just still have the same
conversation
uh to some degree whether it's
hands-free i could be outside walking
you know
there's all kinds of different things i
can do there is some benefit to
understanding that these virtual
experiences they don't have to be direct
replications of the in-person experience
and actually in some cases they may be
better in the virtual world
uh when they're not directly replicating
the real world and sounds like that's
your experience with that with the
product
absolutely and what's interesting is one
of my co-hosts for big ideas
antonio garcia martinez has this amazing
thesis that he's written about
um about how we're moving to an oral
tradition as a society
that actually a lot of our products even
twitter that they're that
they're even though they seem like
text-based products they're actually
much more of
an oral tradition and how people
remember things and and kind of how they
speak and
how how memory actually plays tricks on
us in terms of how information flows
and what's really interesting about that
is that you know clubhouse is an oral
platform
it is this ephemeral oral platform where
stories are being passed down and
conversations are happening and it's
very different
than how things worked you know when we
were writing long emails and that sort
of thing and kind of living that sort of
society so
i i do think that it's perfect for the
times we are living in i actually think
people want more of an ephemeral
platform as well i love that it's not
recorded
uh the element of surprise but also the
idea that you can say things that
otherwise you'd be
you know podcasts are great but as i'm
sure you know better than anyone else
people are more guarded on podcasts than
they are when they think that they
are not being recorded and so i think
that that's part of the magic as well
and i i hope that magic stays
it almost feels like on a podcast uh in
many cases people feel like they're
presenting
right there there's some preparation
they think about what they want to say
uh they know it's recorded they know
that it will be viewed it'll kind of
exist forever
and therefore uh there's less
exploration uh and there's much more
just like here's what i think here
here's what i feel about a certain topic
or issue
um with clubhouse and other types of
audio platforms that aren't recorded
the exploration i think that's part of
the magic that i've noticed is just
people get on and they're like well you
know i don't know what i think about
that well how do you think about it and
there's more of this kind of learning
that happens
uh and people are less afraid to maybe
not sound stupid but
to go through that exploration process
you know somewhat in public or
semi-public
uh with whoever's in the room um and so
that to me just feels like naturally
uh that's the magic that you i and
others that we know
uh enjoying private conversation and
it's now just kind of with a bigger
group of people
and a virtual experience right yeah yeah
absolutely and and i i do think there
there's also this element of delight
that doesn't
mean the other platforms are so robust
and seasoned in many ways that they know
exactly what you want to listen to based
on your taste and based on your past
history
and that actually has made it harder to
discover new things
and so what what i love about clubhouse
is the things that i have seen
are things i never would search for and
ever think to search for sometimes don't
even know exist
uh but a curious person can can learn a
lot from listening to to people whom
they would never interact with
and so that's also been one of the
things that i've loved is you know
listening to the the shoot your shot
ladies uh
talk about things that that you know my
old self like would never
never know about it's been great like i
you know it's hard it's hard to peel
your ears away
i i love it you previously were a
reporter
at uh the washington post um what's your
take
uh it seems like the uh public narrative
is
uh silicon valley versus the world right
or silicon valley versus the press
um and it feels like there's platforms
like clubhouse there's uh platforms like
sub stack
uh twitter even where people now can go
direct they can tell their story
uh they don't necessarily need to go
through that same power structure
historically where they would need the
press to be the the amplification of the
message
uh at the same time uh given that you
worked at the washington post i'm
assuming
uh but correct me if i'm wrong that uh
you believe in journalism and the
importance of journalism and kind of
holding those in power and influence
accountable so just
how do you view this is there a
framework you use you know what what is
kind of true what is just frankly a
public narrative that's uh overblown
uh between like media and silicon valley
and going direct versus the traditional
power structure
so the media versus tech story i
actually think is part of a much broader
story
that the the press is missing and i've
told a lot of my reporter friends this
and part of it is because
this is what's happening to them they
see an attack on them and so they're
they're writing it but i actually think
it's part of this broader devolution of
institutions that we've been talking
about
and you know the elite press is one of
those major institutions that is
devolving
it is part of this lack of institutional
trust we you know if you look at pew
research forum and a number of you know
uh incredible studies that have come out
in the last few years it's very clear
that americans and broadly people across
the world just no longer trust
elite institutions and this is true this
is the same motivation
uh that led to brexit it's the same
motivation that led to donald trump
being elected
uh to the white house like there all of
these factors kind of come together in
this idea that
a lot of people do not trust the elite
institutions that were built in the 20th
century or just before
um and so yes the new york times and the
washington post
actually fit that model um you know
elite media
has the same problems the same sort of
trends we're talking about in terms of
bifurcation of society where some people
have completely different experiences
coming
out of elite universities uh than does
the rest of the country
and so there is sort of this um
you know hesitation to trust these
institutions now i also think there's a
broader issue of transparency
there there was this you know view that
the internet and transparency was going
to lead to kind of greater communication
from these elite institutions
to the people and what has happened is
that there's greater skepticism and
that's sort of a natural
consequence of transparency and so when
you kind of add up all of these factors
i i think there's just a need for new
institutions and and that's sort of the
the underlying
thing that i think is happening in media
we've had one iteration of that and
and from 2010 to 2014 when i was at the
washington post there were a lot of
people
spinning off companies using cheap
venture capital in order to build
companies and we've now seen
the results of that kind of wave of
company building by
seasoned veterans and media and most of
them have failed um
and and i think the new kind of uh
architecture that we are seeing is the
substance architecture which is
you are either going to work for an
elite institution and be part of the
establishment company
uh the middle has has completely
bottomed out there's you know even the
miami herald which was an amazing paper
when i was growing up uh is no longer
um you know a paper that that people
look to as sort of a voice of reason or
sort of you know something that they're
they're subscribing to
so even like the great papers that
existed 30 years ago no longer
exist in the same iterations uh and and
what i think is happening is that anyone
who is talented uh that has a following
on twitter that can build
build for themselves um is going to sub
stack and they're building their own
platform and and you're a perfect
example of this where you've built an
incredible media platform um through
podcasts and through newsletters and and
i think that more and more people are
going to see that's possible and they're
going to do it
one of the things that i've seen it for
sure and kind of this idea of going
direct is
uh what was old becomes new again
uh in some weird way which uh now all of
a sudden all of these pr people are
hitting me up and they're like hey we
want to pitch you this story
uh right with the idea that i'm probably
gonna be more friendly to a startup than
let's say the uh
the traditional press and so uh it
really makes you question like for
somebody in my seat who's built the big
audience and has the ability to go
direct like
do you want to just replicate the whole
media right and the kind of the media
approach of like okay i'm going to
report the latest fundraising round or
i'm going to report
um you know on whatever the partnership
is and where i came out on it was just
like
no that's not what i want right and and
what is more important to me is the
exploration of the ideas and kind of my
personal opinion and kind of what i'm
doing
and what i found is that it actually
attracts a very very different type of
audience right the people who would
listen to this podcast or
uh who would read the content that i put
out is really different than the people
who are attracted to just the latest
fundraising
uh kind of announcements and so it
ultimately brings up this idea of uh
when you
intersect exploration of ideas direct to
uh an audience and kind of uh this idea
of free speech
right where there's ideas that we want
to talk about
that maybe might be taboo to the
mainstream press or
actually maybe are overblown or
questions that we want to ask not
because we necessarily are
uh conspiracy theorists or extremists or
kind of any of the labels that you put
on it but simply because we're trying to
understand and
uh you know are fearful that if you end
up labeling certain questions as
out of bounds things you cannot ask
things you cannot talk about
um it ends up getting closer and closer
to uh
kind of monolithic almost religious
thought processes right and you don't
get the progress
and so how do you see that playing out
right and maybe substance a good
place to kind of have the conversation
around where uh you've got a lot of what
i'll call independent thinkers people
who write
um you know their own ideas they've
moved to sub stack from these large
publications
and you already see the kind of
groundswell of backlash of
you know substance you cannot have these
people use your platform they're sharing
kind of scary ideas or dangerous ideas
but that almost feels like that's
antithetical to free speech
and so just how do you view this and
where are we going with
it you know i mean to i mean the short
answer your question is i would argue
that it is antithetical to free speech
but the
the interesting thing that i think a lot
of people have forgotten and haven't
lived through and and just
or maybe don't know is that you know the
culture of media that we used to have
was far more akin to sub stack than it
is to
the very unique newspaper culture that
we've had since the 1950s
and that was a function of business
model that was a function of
every major you know the consolidation
of newspapers uh
advertisers wanted neutral platforms so
like
you know large companies like macy's and
gm
did not want to advertise in pamphlets
anymore they wanted to
advertise and papers that had a neutral
voice
and so the product of media actually fit
advertising
and that's why it evolved so that it's
not just complete opinion it's
it was we need to have this sort of
neutral voice and anyone who's worked in
reporting knows that the way that you
report a story is you have a lead and
then you have a nut graph and you're
supposed to put the most important
information in the funnel
on the first five inches and we measure
how long a story is in inches because it
was you know produced on a paper not the
internet
it's like that is such a backwards way
of thinking about things
since the emergence of the internet and
so that
that to me is what i think people are
missing is that a lot of our media
culture
was there because we were delivering a
paper every day
uh and we were delivering it and it was
completely
funded not just by subscribers but by
advertisers
and so when the business model shifted
of course advertising
advertising is so important but when the
business model shifted as it has
and particularly something like sub
stack where people are paying for
content
the idea that you know that it has to be
completely neutral
and and the way that you're reporting i
actually think people don't necessarily
want neutral
uh people have sort of given up on the
idea that humans can be neutral in their
reporting or in the way that they cover
uh narratives and and you know for a
long time i'd say like most of history
we were in a pamphlet culture where
people understood that it was like no
one's ever going to be neutral
everyone's always going to kind of have
their underlying
you know beliefs in what they're writing
and so i don't think it's necessarily a
bad thing that the culture is moving in
a direction where people are open about
what they believe
i think for a while we were sort of you
know larping that we're all unbiased um
and trying really hard like you know
when i was a reporter i
i very much tried to you know stay to
the facts
uh like write straight stories the sad
part about that was i couldn't make any
money doing that
and and even within you know like i was
never going to to raise through the
ranks
being a straight reporter and i think
that's also one of the fundamental
problems in media
is since the emergence of twitter if you
really want to make a voice for yourself
if you really want to convince your
employer that they need to pay you more
or that they need to give you a better
beat
you have to show that you have a
following and who's going to have a
following
just tweeting headlines all day without
any sort of opinion on twitter
so i think the the media culture has
completely shifted
it's not necessarily a bad thing but i
think we have to own up to the fact that
you know great reporters are going to
have biases and preferences and if
they're writing in a voice that people
like
they should be able to monetize that
voice in an independent way
and if they want to if they want to stay
at the big papers great
uh but the big papers are also starting
to go that direction as well just
because of
twitter and sort of the function of what
technology forces them to do
it it is so funny to hear you say this
the extreme example is
you know i always say how can you be
unbiased if you've never written
uh a negative story about something or
you've never written a positive story
about something right if all of your
coverage is slanted in one direction
it's impossible to be uh an unbiased
person by the way
none of us are unbiased right it is okay
to have bias just
say what your bias is and then just
state your opinion and people will
uh will kind of follow suit and if they
uh so desire and
you know really put the impetus on
people not to just live in an echo
chamber but go seek out those dissenting
opinions which obviously is difficult
uh but but i think it definitely changes
it and the other thing too is it seems
to have
become uh in some weird way especially
in uh
more vertical specific like financial
media etc uh
for any sort of criticism of uh those
institutions right it almost feels like
if i'm under attack i don't want to also
put under attack
those like me and so i've even gone as
far as to say you know around like let's
say the stimulus packages and the
federal reserve if you look
at a lot of the coverage across
mainstream media it's almost as if the
financial media has become a mouthpiece
for the state
they just regurgitate those same talking
points and some of it may be
business product uh you're trying to
kind of conform to that and make sure
that they don't upset advertisers
but there's just not a lot of
independent thinking going on and that
doesn't mean that independent thinking
against talking points makes the
independent thinkers uh correct and the
talking point's wrong it just means that
there's no kind of criticism there's no
kind of critical thinking going on
which obviously is dangerous for our
society as a whole
continuing on this uh in terms of your
experience as a washington post reporter
uh you have talked a lot about this idea
that great companies follow a lot of the
same ingredients have a great story
just expand on that what do you mean
when you say great companies are similar
to great stories
yeah so i you know i i'm an early stage
investor so i
often meet founders at the idea stage
sometimes they have nothing built
um and you know i think a lot of people
on the outside when they look at venture
capital they think that you have to be
a financial genius that you're looking
at spreadsheets all day
that you're you know really you know
thinking through that
that element of business building which
is very important especially at the
later stages
but early stage investing is this very
unique combination of what i say is
reason and revelation
um like you're looking for secrets
you're looking for
things that somehow these amazing
founders know that you don't
um and you're trying to also make a
reasonable argument as to why they are
going to build a game-changing company
and so what's interesting about that is
that that's all narrative
that's all storytelling a founder will
come in i used to say founder came into
the office
a founder will meet on zoom you know and
and we'll tell you a story in 30 minutes
and the
the indicator of whether you're going to
invest is is this story
exceptional is this person the right
protagonist to
to build this exceptional thing are they
going to be able i mean one of the
things i
often say is i look for people who have
posses people who have
just a group of people who follow them
wherever they go
because whatever they are doing in their
daily life is so extraordinary whatever
they are saying
is so um you know they're so good at
evangelizing a mission
that people will follow them and i think
that is sort of the
the key to early stage company building
you have to find
people who have extraordinary views of
where the future is going
uh they are committed to those views so
they're almost
maniacal in many ways about how
committed they are to those views where
you you look at them and you say like
okay you've clearly had to defend
this contrarian thesis in front of
others before and that's why you're so
committed to it
so there's a lot of characteristics that
i look for and i'd say that's very
similar to what you look for in a great
story when you're reporting
uh you're looking for something people
haven't heard before you're looking for
an
interesting protagonist who can carry
the story i know you know some investors
say that it's a lot like movie making
you know i think it's like reporting a
news story or a feature story
you're looking for that person who's
just extraordinary has an interesting
spark
and they've told you something that you
find to be
you know something you've never heard
before and then
the key question on the reason element
is is it plausible
like is this actually a plausible thing
you know sometimes people will say
things that i'm not not powders
necessarily but it's like you know
like it actually has to be something
that could be achievable but
that's when you then decide like is this
someone who i i
you know want to support on a 10 20 year
journey um
which is is very similar that's the
difference is that you're not
um as a reporter you're not with someone
for 10 20 years
but i but i love that's the part i love
the most is that you're actually making
a huge commitment of your of your
capital and your time
to work with a person as they achieve an
extraordinary mission
i think you've described it previously
the three things that i put in my notes
were uh
what make a great company and a great
story a universal appeal
imperfect protagonist and then an
important mission that
must be accomplished right or achieved
and to me
it's um it's a very interesting thing
when you are really
embodying in those three points many of
uh what
most venture capitalists who have had
any level of success would identify in
terms of founder
market fit right the ability to
storytell not because it helps you raise
capital but it helps you sign
partnership deals and recruit employees
and kind of do all the things that are
necessary
from actual company building but you
also highlighted
a very interesting idea uh you said in
30 minutes someone can tell the story
and you can start to really understand
you know yes or no right to some degree
and there's always diligence in all of
that but it reminds me a lot of uh
warren buffett
right who would say hey i know whether
i'm going to do a multi-billion dollar
deal
in the first couple of minutes of a
phone call right and so
it really does feel like uh the details
matter
but what matters much more is who the
person is and kind of the story that
they're telling and
it sounds like a lot of the uh the
underwriting that you're doing in a
pitch is frankly on that
yeah no and and i actually think early
stage investing is much more of an art
than a science i tell people i listen to
a lot more of how i'm feeling than what
i'm hearing
um and you know if you listen to like i
actually think the feeling is probably a
better you know some people call it gut
check
the feeling of what you feel like in a
meeting with someone
is exactly what's going to happen with a
candidate it's exactly what's going to
happen with a customer and a sales pitch
it's what's going to happen when a
person is talking to the media what's
going to happen when
when when the founder is interacting
with anyone that feeling
is something that you have to look for
and it it
you know no one it it's it's not like
traditional investing in that regard
because there
aren't numbers to go off of there
there's only a story to go off of when
you're investing at the seed stage or
and sometimes at the series a stage too
the way markets are like there there
aren't that many things
on the rational side of investing to
look at and so you do have all of these
factors of
you know is does does what the founder
is is what the founders saying
you know it could it be an extraordinary
business and and i hate even saying like
that you need to look at the business
element of this because
when you look at someone like elon musk
what he was saying
in in the early 2000s about building
rockets like it was crazy
it was it was it was testing the limits
of science
and so even if you said is that a good
business it was fundamentally not a good
business because it had government as a
customer
and it didn't even make sense from like
a scientific perspective to most of the
leading experts
it was just a person who was so
convinced that they could push the
boundaries and
the limitations of humanity and so
that's the other thing that i
that i really like to stress is that
there are some people who are so
extraordinary
extraordinary that even if they are
saying things that don't rationally
compute
sometimes like sometimes they work and
sometimes they build the most
extraordinary companies and so
um you know that's why i think i take
some meetings that are seen to be a
little fringe or i invest in things that
oftentimes are not sort of traditional
um you know areas of venture capital
because i do believe in those types of
people
and it really is a question of believing
in those people
yeah and so as you kind of think through
this uh and you just highlighted it
right there which is
a lot of times what you'll end up doing
is you end up investing
in things that uh don't seem to be uh
a good business uh they may even be
somewhat controversial when you first
invest in them how do you
separate like what is the process you
personally go through or things that you
do
uh being able to uh understand hey i
need to think independently here i need
to be open-minded about things that may
seem crazy
uh controversial or kind of outside of
the norm uh but also making sure that
you don't end up
you know investing in q and on and next
you know you're like in the extremist
views of
of the deep dark uh depths of the
internet like like
how do you basically you know not follow
the herd but at the same
time always be able to gut check uh on
that rational aspect of like is there
something here
uh from an investment standpoint yeah so
i'm a huge believer in the socratic
method
that uh you know i've been a student of
political philosophy for
my entire life um and i believe that
like right like just rabid questioning
of people actually leads to truth
um and so you know if someone could come
in and have a beautiful pitch
and they could say something that sounds
great but if they can't go three layers
deep
if they can't interact with the
questions if they can't be pushed on
their theses and their beliefs
in a way that is believable to to me
then that that doesn't meet my bar i
think that the people who
have thought deeply about something
controversial they're not just saying
something controversial
they actually have metrics and history
to back them up
and what's amazing to me about i think
the best founders is a lot of them are
also extraordinary historians
they know everything about the industry
and why it doesn't
work the way they want it to they know
everything about the customers who who
they're going to go after even if they
haven't had interactions with those
customers yet
i mean it's it's an encyclopedic
knowledge
about how they are building the story
that
can't be faked and so if someone is
saying something
you know and i use defense as a good
example of this if someone is saying
that they're going to change the
department of defense but they don't
know anything about how procurement
works
and you start asking them questions
about it and they don't know they're
probably not going to be as good of a
founder in that sector as someone who
says here's
what is wrong here's why it's wrong and
here's how i'm going to change it in the
step-by-step process
and so when you're you know meeting with
early stage founders
those are the things that i look for and
i think it's important
to to explain like you don't have to
have all the answers
and i think the best founders know that
they don't have all the answers they're
going to have to pressure test a lot of
their theses
in the wild uh but but they understand
kind of the consequences of their
choices and they understand why they
believe the things that they do and can
express them
very well um and if a founder can do
that
i mean that is that is a huge
indicator in my opinion of whether
someone is going to be able to recruit
well
whether they're going to be able to
build a company at the earliest of
stages and more importantly whether
they're going to be able to kind of
weather
the the you know ups and downs of
building a company um
what you're really talking about is
you're investing in people right and
uh and i think that there's a lot of
folks who say uh they invest in people
there's a lot of people who will say
they invest in products and then some
that will invest in markets and
uh it might take from uh kind of what i
know about you in our conversation today
is it's kind of people and markets are
the two things that really
um you're focused on how do you think
about
uh the individual in terms of are there
specific things that you're looking for
outside of just their their depth of uh
understanding
in a specific industry are there you
know if you ask a chris sacca he would
say hey
uh i'm looking for people who uh have
previously worked blue collar jobs and
so there's some element of like you know
being
down to earth or to understanding hard
work there's other people who have you
know whatever their kind of thing is
um is there something that you really
latch on to look for or maybe specific
questions that you use
uh when evaluating uh an opportunity
that kind of get at specific things that
people may not think about when uh when
investing
yeah you know i i used to say that i
look for and i've sort of changed my
views on this but i used to say that i
i look for people who have narratives
that don't necessarily make sense
and i think the the thing where i've
realized that i'm wrong there is there's
a lot of people who have kind of
normal normal narratives like they they
had they
grew up in a normal home and they went
to normal school and they worked a
normal job and they built an amazing
company and it's like how do they do
that
and so i i sort of moved my okay i'm
looking only at the story and only at
the facts
to what are the traits that can come up
even in a 30-minute conversation
and the thing that i'm really looking
for are you know people who
are very confident going against the
grain people who just have backbones of
steel and part of the reason
why i think this is so important and
this is i think a new phenomena
uh that maybe didn't exist 10 years ago
but if you are building a company
that is going to be a massive success
you are going to have a massive target
on your back from the very beginning of
it looking successful uh the minute that
it seems as though your company is doing
well
people are going to be coming out of the
woodwork to try to destroy you
and so the character required to be a
founder of a company to stay true to
your beliefs
is extraordinary and you have to look
for signs earlier in life of when
someone
has stood up to authority when someone
has
you know done taken the hard path like
what is the hard thing that you've done
and even if it's you know
i i dropped out of school to take care
of my mother or i you know i i
moved to a new country uh to to and
didn't know any of the languages
like like there has to be something
where people looked at you in your past
and said what are you doing with your
life like what are you throwing away
why are you taking this this risk
because the pressure is so extraordinary
for any early stage founder and any
founder right now so
those are the things i'm looking for but
i think i used to say you know i'm
looking for someone who has sort of that
oh i dropped out of college or i did
something that
is so clearly something that was not
normal and i'd actually say now dropping
out of college is seen as like pretty
normal if you want to be a founder so
actually maybe the opposite of like
staying in college when you shouldn't um
but but i'm looking for
you know when did you go against your
family when did you go against your
culture when did you go against society
and when did when were there
repercussions but you stayed strong
because of it because
throughout a 10 20 year journey of
building a company there's going to be
just a lot of people
trying to pull you down and you just
have to be a strong person who doesn't
listen to them and doesn't care
this really gets at one of the uh the
things that i've noticed over the last
maybe two to four years uh is there's
been such great democratization
of uh information uh for early stage
startups uh both from a fundraising
standpoint a company building standpoint
uh and so every once in a while i'll
come across somebody and they will
literally say
every single thing that is the right
thing uh but it just feels like they
read the yc blog post right and they're
doing what somebody told them to do
uh rather than it be the authentic thing
that they're supposed to do
and so you know it's one of these things
where it's nearly impossible in some
situations to
bifurcate those two things uh but it
does feel like that is one of the risks
uh is that there were certain things
that were signals for investors
previously
that hey this person has a higher
probability of being successful
but when somebody then goes and writes a
blog post about it and you know hundred
thousand people read it and they all
start repeating the same thing or doing
the same thing
uh you've really got to kind of sift
through and get who is this person
rather than what are they saying or
kind of what the actions are that
they're taking absolutely
yeah um before i let you go i always ask
everyone the same three questions and
you'll get to ask me one to
finish up uh the first is what is the
most important book that you've ever
read oh
so i i'm uh i love books uh but i'd say
that the
the book that's had the the greatest
impact on me is plato's republic
uh and it i it's funny so little known
story
my my father was a jesuit priest for 10
years
before before leaving the the order and
and and becoming a doctor uh but he
always said that he missed the jesuits
greatly and of course the jesuits when
he was born were
were very into greek philosophy um and
he introduced me to plato's republic
when i was about 13 years old of course
i did not understand it
at all um and studied it throughout life
studied throughout college and can
you know continuously go back to it as a
book that i think explains the world
better than any other book that exists
but but i had it in my life at a very
very early stage
and political philosophy and
particularly the socratic method
was a huge part of my upbringing and
just how i
approached the world um so if you
haven't read plato's republic even
though it is it is a slog
i recommend it because i think there's
more truth in that book than probably
any truth
any other book that is a fantastic
suggestion no one suggests that one yet
second question comes from our friends
over at uh eight sleep uh i used to
sleep like five or six
hours um and uh frankly thought that was
normal and then i got this eight sleep
and now i sleep like eight or nine
sleep on this ice cube of their
thermoregulated bed and feel like my
life has changed uh drastically
i know you have a newborn but uh
how is uh how is your sleep schedule
these days and how has that changed over
time
uh i was like salivating what i heard
five or six hours of sleep my gosh that
sounds amazing yeah i'd love i'd love to
have that happen
um you know i i i this is like such a a
funny time i love the eight sleep people
sleep is so important i've always been
obsessed with sleep i've always been a
firm believer in getting
you know i can sleep anywhere like you
know i've always been a firm believer
that sleep is important i'm glad to see
the resurgence of people focusing on it
um from a science perspective
uh in terms of like my sleep patterns
right now
i'm just hoping one day like that i'm
able to sleep through the night again
i'm sure new parents all feel this way
where
you're just like it's never gonna go
back to normal i've heard it does um
but i'm also you know the other thing
i'm excited about is you know
establishing a sleep habit is probably
the most important thing you could do
for yourself and so
to look on the bright side of being up
every few hours
the exciting thing is when you have a
child then you can establish healthy
patterns for that child
and so i'm really excited you know i
used to be a night owl i i am a night
owl
really re-establishing that pattern
because now i'm looking after another
human life and i want them to have
healthier sleep patterns
that's the thing i'm looking forward to
most uh and hopefully that will keep me
honest about making sure i get enough
sleep so that so that he does as well
that's a great way of looking at i
always joke that whenever i ask somebody
about sleep it's kind of like a crossfit
if they have a young child that's the
first thing that anyone will say right
because they're like i got a young kid
so uh you know bear with me
uh third question uh last question you
get to ask me one is uh aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
of course and i don't know what
iteration they they are in
uh i think we're all going to be
surprised uh
you know i'm hoping that that i mean i'm
assuming that there will be
some information about this in our
lifetimes i think we'll all be surprised
as to
to you know what form factor it is but i
i think you know
the vast majority of people who have
studied this uh
are are of the belief that like yes of
course like
and and you know how they'll interact
with us and i'm looking forward to
seeing it but i also don't know how i'm
going to react
um and how i'm going to uh take in the
actual information
when when it actually happens yeah i uh
the only thing that recently
uh thought made me think hey maybe this
might be happening faster than we
thought
was i don't know if you saw the
cephalopod that passed a uh like an
intelligence test uh geared towards like
a young child
and i was like you know look i don't
know the details whatever but the fact
that uh everyone always thinks of aliens
is like this like
foreign concept way out in space and
then all of a sudden if it just came out
like no listen like actually there's
intelligent life in the ocean that
uh you know all of you idiots all
thought was just some stupid animal
uh is smarter than our children like i
think all of a sudden people start to
really question you know the
what is an alien right and kind of how
do we think about that so
yeah uh you get to ask me one question
to finish up what uh what one question
you have for me
yeah so i you know i am a firm believer
in public service but i've never
served in the military i've never you
know served my country and
you have i'd i'd love to hear the the
major lesson that you've taken away from
that
uh yeah it's pretty simple we're all
gonna die um
which is uh somewhat of a morbid uh
takeaway but i think that the the big
thing was um i went when i was
uh i joined the military when i was 17
years old but uh at 20
was deployed to uh iraq and um you know
was there at a time where we were um as
a country engaged in heavy combat
uh in two basically battlefields uh
and you know there was uh the lucky
situation of
all the guys that i went with came back
uh alive
uh but also some of the people that we
were there with did not and so what you
end up realizing is like
you learn this lesson at 20 of if we're
all gonna die i better enjoy it while
i'm here
and so what it really kind of taught me
was uh
to kind of not worry so much about all
of the frivolous things that maybe i
would have worried about and you know
life that uh had i not had that lesson
but also too is uh really what are you
gonna do while you're here
right and to have that kind of
conversation with yourself or that
thought process at 20 i think most
people might have that when they're
you know 40 45 50 maybe even literally
on their deathbed
uh but it was a pretty kind of
life-changing experience uh
because what it forced me to really say
to myself is like what is what are you
pursuing and
you know ultimately i came to this
conclusion of like happiness and not in
the like
you know uh kind of enlightened i
meditate for an hour every day and that
to me is happiness but just more so
uh when faced with decisions throughout
the day or
kind of the years uh i just choose to do
the things that i want to do
right it's kind of it just removes a lot
of the [ __ ] frankly and
uh i think that that's probably been one
of the the great guiding lights and it
all comes from that experience so it's
pretty cool to have that at such a young
age yeah that's amazing to have purpose
at such such a young age too i think
that's a lot of what
young people are missing today they're
searching for purpose and to have that
gift
uh even if it's delivered in a hard way
but that gift of purpose given to you at
a young age is truly amazing
absolutely catherine listen thank you so
much for taking the time to do this
where can we send people to
find you on the internet and find some
of your writing or if anyone wants to
reach out with uh investment
opportunities
certainly so i write it at
boyle.substance.com i'm
at catherine on clubhouse and my twitter
is uh at ktm boyle
so i'd be excited to meet people at any
of those places
awesome listen thank you so much for uh
for doing this we'll have to do it again
in the future
absolutely thanks so much